ensuite donc donc on engage des
discussions et cetera ont conclu
programme commun mais qu'est ce que fait
françois mitterrand dans la nuit mais
nous avons signé le programme commun je
crois 2 heures du matin deux heures plus
tard à quatre enfants il était tard
quatre heures du matin plutôt qu'est ce
que veut françois mitterrand il prend
l'avion il s'en va vienne devant
l'internationale socialiste
l'internationale socialiste le critique
il leur dit me rassurez vous mes amis
j'ai signé le programme commun pour
prendre trop mignon de veau parti
communiste français
par conséquent contrairement à ce qu est
l engagement qu avec des prix entre le
parti socialiste et nous dans le constat
que nous avions fait à la pinte 70
françois mitterrand n'a signé de
programmes communs comme que comme un
moyen d'affaiblir le parti communiste
français
ce sera sa ligne constante contre
laquelle nous allons devoir guter de
1972 à 1977 leurs deux fils et en 1977
j'en aurai terminé de ma démonstration
parce que là encore il a dit une contre
vérité que vous n'avez pas relevé quand
il est question c'est georges marchais
qui en 1977 le premier sur la question
de politique extérieure a remis en cause
de programme pair est une qui contient
juillet bien messieurs sur le troc le
nom il
ça s'est passé le 28 juillet j'étais en
corse avec ma femme devant la télévision
et quand j'ai entendu françois
mitterrand c'était à 13h quand j'ai
entendu françois mitterrand refusé de
s'engager sur l'existence d'une défense
nationale indépendante
j'ai dit à ma femme françois mitterrand
a décidé d'abandonner le programme comme
à gauche c'est les valises
on rentre à paris et nous sommes rentrés
à paris et nous sommes rentrés à paris
et ses tout débuts daoud qu'à la
télévision
je me suis expliquée sur cette question
là alors quand une qui ressort de sa une
chose oui il ressent j'ai voulu faire ce
brin d'histoire pour montrer qu'en
définitive la politique d'union de la
gauche pour françois mitterrand n'a
toujours pas constitué qu'une manoeuvre
destinée
essayer d'affaiblir le parti communiste
français et